dames messieurs membres du conseil
national je me présente je m'appelle
mohamed vous faire mal je suis arrivé en
france en 2012 je vais intégrer sciences
po paris et c'est avec grande fierté que
je m'exprime devant vous c'est pas pour
une question c'est plus pour un
témoignage parce que je pense que c'est
essentiel aujourd'hui de vent témoigner
monsieur le président je me suis engagé
en politique
peut-être grâce à vous parce que je vous
ai toujours suivi au maroc je vous
regarde et je regardais vos interviews
et je suis arrivé en france et j'ai
trouvé la france dans un état désastreux
j'ai trouvé que les débats en france
était très violent par rapport à
différents sujets et je voulais apporter
mon point de vue monsieur guaino vous
parlez de votre famille politique
permettez moi de vous parler de la
mienne celle des républicains qui m'a
accueilli et qui me laisse m'exprimer
librement dans cette famille politique
une famille politique qui m'a donné une
carte des républicains avant ma carte
électorale
et ça je pense que c'est essentiel de
levier aujourd'hui et je profite de la
présence de tous les journalistes pour
en témoigner
donc voilà je voulais remercier la
famille des républicains
le conseil national et je voulais vous
dire que c'est un long chemin qui se
trace devant nous et devant ce parti
pour continuer à défendre les valeurs de
la droite
les vraies valeurs de la france et vive
la france vive la république
merci pour ce témoignage émouvant